people in the town of prevalier in
Slovenia can do nothing but watch on is
a torrent of water cuts through their
landscape
Rivers forming where once there were
roads
people's entire lives washed away
the bridge collapsed then debris got
stuck to it as it headed towards the
house last night at 4 pm they evacuated
us with helicopters we thought the house
would stand because the flood waters
were still far away but it collapsed at
1am
more rain has fallen in Slovenia in the
last few days than in a month
the ground in many regions can't absorb
any more rainfall creating new waterways
and causing rivers to rise to record
levels
with his home gone this man believes the
climate is trying to send the world a
message
we all know how it is in the whole world
at the moment nature is fighting back
for all we've done water has the power
it destroys everything
businesses are ruined and mop-up
operations are underway in areas where
there's been some respite from the
flooding
this is the first time it has been this
bad it happened once in 1990 although
there was very little water compared to
this it's awful we put water protection
on the doors but nothing helped
everything was ripped apart by the water
it was terrible
set alarm
near the Austrian border with entire
areas submerged police are having to
Ferry people to safety
meanwhile the Army remains on standby
for deployment as the situation gets
worse
slovenia's environment agency has issued
a warning for yet more flooding
Michael Apple Al Jazeera
foreign